[Musique]
des balances
il en existe de toutes les sortes nous
avons donc limiter notre banc d'essai a
dit balance électronique compactes elles
se vendent entre 16 et 70 dollars notre
collaborateur frédéric chabot test pour
nous deux modèles à qr 2 stars frites de
et scali une cuisine art une ricardo une
oxo et une aux ris la balance ça sert à
avoir vraiment une quantité précise
d'ingrédients sont matures de toujours
avoir le même résultat est un instrument
aussi à partir il a balancé beaucoup
plus précise que la tasse à mesurer
prenons l'exemple de la cassonade la
cassonade si je la dépose et doucement
dans la transe à mesurer pour 1 2 tasse
à 325 g versus si la compacte vraiment
beaucoup
alors on est à 4 180 grands parents une
différence d'auto 30 33 % en termes de
poids ce qui peut vraiment altéré la
texture et le goût de nos biscuits alors
pour savoir quelle balance des marques
un test de précision est primordial
existe des poils le standardisés qui
sont certifiés dont on utilise cipolla
donc toujours faire un test au centre et
idéalement aussi dans les quatre coins
du moins à quatre endroits différents au
test de précision avec un poids de 500
grammes tout les balances sont
performants il a aux ris avec les poids
standard
vraiment marquer 100 % avec un poids
beaucoup plus petits 2 g 4 balance
refuse de faire une lecture par contre
la balance et scali fait très bonne
figure et c'est la plus dispendieuse à
60 dollars mais les plus dispendieux
aussi parce qu'il est beaucoup plus
précise cette balance pour peser au
dixième de gramme au dixième de gramme
c'est utile seulement si vous faites de
la cuisine moléculaire
plus important la facilité de lecture
seulement un grand tableau d'affichage
très visible qui est rétro éclairé ce
qu'on veut c'est l'information que la
balance donne l'autre grande qualité
aussi faut vraiment que la balance
puissent allumer ce taré élire le poids
rapidement tard et cela veut dire peser
un récipient avant de le remplir afin de
pouvoir déduire son poids du total
je dors ici tout ce qu'on peut utiliser
n'importe quel contenu il se sache pu en
effet peser plusieurs ingrédients
successivement les uns par dessus les
eaux dans le même contenant la moitié
des balances ne passe pas le test de
visibilité avec un gros bol la basse oxo
qui est une balance à plateaux acide
speak son gros avantage c'est que
l'afficheur peut se déplacer
donc s'il utilise un gros bol pour poser
une grande quantité d'ingrédients mais
je suis sûr de pouvoir le voir la
facilité de nettoyage est un facteur à
considérer
je les aime plus ou moins parce que
c'est difficile d'aller la vie en
dessous ici et c'est fragile existe
généralement deux types de capteurs sur
les balances alors à l'origine c'était
toujours un capteur qui étaient à
l'intérieur de la base et le plateau qui
pesait qui appuyait sur le capteur et
qui mesurait le poids depuis quelques
années on retrouve aussi des balances
avec des capteurs qui sont sous la
balance
donc ce qui permet de vraiment d'avoir
une surface unie qui se nettoie
facilement
c'est le cas de ces trois modèles avec
peu d'ouverture pour magie des saletés
toutes les balances dispose d'unités
métriques et impérial et presque toutes
ont le mode volumétrie mais est ce
vraiment utile
elle pèse 100 grammes d'eau qui équivaut
à 100 millilitres d'eau mais le danger
c'est que pour de l'huile par exemple
qui pèse 89 grande pour 100 millilitres
ça fonctionne pauvres
le sirop d'érable ses 130 g pour 100
millilitres
donc c'est un peu faux de dire que c'est
balance l'eau peuvent mesurer un volume
en millilitres
le modèle ricardo a franchement le plus
beau design du groupe
mais il reste difficile à opérer les
boutons se retrouve sur la façade avant
c'est des petits boutons un effleurement
c'est très difficile à contrôler en
termes de look
cet accueil wade est là et scali ne
donnent pas leur place là est ce qu'elle
est ici fonctionne quand même assez bien
mais pour moins cher je peux avoir une
meilleure performance
c'est le cas des deux balances préféré
de frédéric l' accueil qui s'avère être
la moins coûteuse contrôle sans simple
changer quand même assez clair et sa
favorite la aux ris elles réagissent
super rapidement elle se mue rapidement
le temps rapidement
le poids celui super v est l'écran est
bien visible aussi en termes de
performances de conception ou de prix
c'est vraiment la mer
[Musique]